seit dem 11 erfolgen alle meldungen der
labore an die gesundheitsämter
elektronisch nicht mehr per fax sondern
per knopfdruck und direkt dass es
erstens eine enorme zeitersparnis und
zweitens muss nicht mehr vom fax dann
noch per hand übrigens auch durchaus
fehleranfällig das dann ins system
eingegeben werden das gilt seit dem
ersten ersten für alle
nachdem vorher schon viele mitgemacht
hatten wir haben angebote zum
kontaktpersonen management auch dort mit
dem sommers im begriff kennt ja auch
schon bald jeder oder viele als angebot
als software für die gesundheitsämter wo
alle gesundheitsämter die das nutzen uns
berichten dass das eben auch noch mal
enorm arbeit erleichtert personal
ressourcen spart bis übrigens hin zu
einem telefon bot der 40 bis 45 prozent
der telefonanrufe die ein gesundheitsamt
erreichen
zufriedenstellend für die anruferinnen
und anrufer tatsächlich beantworten kann
auch das nochmal eine enorme
erleichterung so dass wir natürlich in
allen bereichen die gesundheitsämter
dabei unterstützen und schon unterstützt
haben aber auch unterstützen wollen
die personalressourcen möglichst
effizient einsetzen zu können
aber das eine ist die nachverfolgung
durch die gesundheitsämter als zielmarke
das andere nicht zuletzt mit blick auf
die mutation ist generell das
infektionsgeschehen so weit es geht zu
minimieren
um eben auch andere anderen
folgewirkungen sei es das
gesundheitswesen sei es andere bereiche
bis hin zur wirtschaft ja dann indirekt
zu reduzieren und wir haben 1 erlebt im
september/oktober wenn einmal incidents
von 30 50 60 erreicht ist dann ist es
sehr sehr schwer das wieder einzufangen
sondern dann geht es sehr sehr schnell
auch sehr hoch in teilen das haben wir
in einigen bundesländern gesehen und wer
wirklich diese pandemie unter kontrolle
halten will muss die zahlen so weit
runter bringen dass das risiko für ein
sehr schnelles neu entflammen eben
weitestgehend minimiert ist
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren